ukraine says it's broken through enemy
lines at several points near the
southern city of hesson it's mounting a
campaign to retake territory occupied by
russia the push comes after weeks of
preparation ukraine has been attacking
russia's supply routes in an attempt to
isolate troops in the area russia
captured cresson early on in the war
ukraine president vladimir lenski is
vowing to push russian forces out of all
occupied territories saying there will
be no place for the invaders on
ukrainian land
ukraine
ukraine is returning its own
and it will return kharkiv luhansk
donetsk saporisha the herson regions
crimea and definitely the waters of the
black and adolf seas
ben hodges is a military expert and
former commander of u.s forces in europe
welcome
ukraine's long been expected to launch
a major counter-offensive is this the
beginning of
it well we're not sure uh the ukrainian
general staff has done a very good job
of protecting information
we know more about the russians than we
do about what ukrainian forces are doing
but certainly the last few weeks we have
seen
effective use of highmars and other
weapons systems to to do what we call
shaping operations to attrib or degrade
russian logistics
artillery and rockets commanding control
it does has the feeling it does have the
feeling of the beginning of something
large um but we're not sure yet there's
a lot more to unfold in the next few
days but would you say that the
ukrainian military has the capacity to
to launch
a successful counter-offensive
yeah i do
again the ukrainian general staff has
done a good job of preparation um they
have resisted the urge to push every new
tank and
every new soldier into the current fight
holding on to them to build up a force
that would be ready
to launch an attack once the conditions
are set on the ground
so what we're seeing for example the
isolation of thousands of russian troops
on the northwest side of the nipro river
for example
the the significant reduction of
artillery from russian side all of these
things are necessary preparations
i think that ukraine if in fact they do
launch their uh offensive
now they will have picked the right time
and place to do it and you say we know
more about the russians how do you
expect them to respond
well of course we're seeing a variety of
reactions from nothing's happening
nothing to see over here to people
panicking both in terms of soldiers but
also even civilians on the russian side
of the border in belgarride
and i think there is great concern the
problem is
the russians have not yet fixed the many
problems that they had that that were on
display back in february and march
especially their command and control
framework for how they make decisions uh
move people around that's it's still a
mess to be candid and their logistical
system is fragile it's exhausted it has
gotten weaker by the uh with every
passing week so they're not as able to
react to changes
in the situation as they as we might
have expected earlier
what about putin last week announcing a
10 increase in russian troops in ukraine
what's that say about the state of the
russian army
well it's very interesting first that um
that they would say that is as a public
acknowledgement that there's a problem
number one
uh number two the um
i i would say that this is a number that
they will never get there
i would bet a large amount of money
there's not 137 000 russians wanting to
step forward and join the military and
in fact there's a tradition in russia of
serious inflation of numbers they've
never had what they said they had but
this is a classic means of corruption to
claim you have a certain number to draw
salaries when in fact you're only paying
about a half to three quarters of that
so now there is a real manpower problem
in russia which is not something that i
would have thought i'd said a few months
ago they just don't have people that
want to get in this fight
and frankly it's a overall
unhealthy population decreasing in size
i don't think they'll ever get to 137
000 and if they did it would be months
before these guys would show up with any
level of training and improper equipment
well let's see if this proves to be a
turning point ben hodges military expert
and former commander thank you
thanks for the privilege
dw's matthias berlinger is in southern
ukraine matthias what are you hearing
about ukraine's offensive
yeah it seems that there are three
points where the ukrainian army uh has
been either heavily put pressure on the
russians or even take back some
territory uh that's uh west of gerson uh
the land bridge that connects it to
macoliff and uh that's uh near the
ingulets river that's the that's where
ukraine has been able to establish a
bridgehead they've been able to cross uh
this river for some time but they have
been basically stuck on that on a piece
of land that they were able uh to set
over to and they seem to have expanded
this area and the third one is further
north that's where the nova cafe dam is
in the direction of the nova kakov
they're not in nova kapoka yet that's a
dam that
is one potential crossing of the river
also the crossings itself has been
destroyed by ukrainian rockets as far as
we understand it's not possible to pass
there now but still it remains an
important strategic point all these
points are still at the distance from
hassan city center it's not that they
are really uh approaching hassan city
center but it's a it's a it's a good
step ahead there
how are the russians responding
we've seen shelling of mikolai for
example mccolive is not far from these
places it's a city that has been
hit by rockets constantly throughout the
past few weeks and that's the same last
night there's also rockets have also
come down near here where i am in
zappoligia and other places so the uh
replied by russia is the one that's
that's usually happening its
rockets on cities
you're not too far from the embattled
nuclear power plant at zafaria is
shelling and fighting still going on
there
yeah that's what we're hearing shelling
has been happening constantly throughout
the past few weeks i must say um and
it seems according to the russian
occupational authorities that this night
again some shells have landed in the
town nearby where the
the the
power plants um
engineers etc live
and
not on the site of the plant itself but
in the past few days we've also seen
something hitting there so um
yes uh this uh
this area is is embattled and uh the
dangers are still there an international
inspector is set to arrive at the plan
tomorrow will they get full and safe
access to the site
nobody knows that i mean there is an
agreement basically that they can travel
there russia has said it will give them
access but what will be on site nobody
knows
what precautions are being taken against
a potential radiation leak
there are many uh security systems in a
nuclear power plant the
reactors themselves are pretty sturdy
as far as we've been hearing a shell
wouldn't be able to break that and and
open up the reactor and release the
energy but the weakest spot are the
cooling systems even if the reactors are
shut off
they need to be cooled for several
months until
the the fuel has really cooled down
enough so it's
safe to leave it without cooling and
these systems they're dependent on
electricity and the most uh dangerous
thing is plus possibly an electricity
cut we've been pretty close to that a
few days ago when the when the plant was
taken off the grid there are generators
that are then supplying uh the energy
but that seems to be the most critical
point to what extent russia has taken
precautions on site enough fuel etc we
don't know that's something the iaea
will have to figure out when they're on
site
mathias berger in zaparicio for us thank
you very much for your reporting
defence ministers from across the
european union are meeting in prague to
discuss the bloc's military support for
ukraine the talks are expected to focus
on setting up eu training for the
ukrainian army to operate western
weapons
here's a look at some of the military
aid that ukraine is receiving
ukraine's ammunition supply is about to
get a boost its howitzer artillery units
will be stocked with a new type of shell
called the volcano
germany says it's sending several
hundred volcano munitions to the front
line the gps and laser-guided missiles
reach up to 80 kilometers almost
doubling the range of most howitzers
already existing donated equipment is
having an impact
there were shellings on
every day
but due to new weapons that were
perceived from the west particularly
jaime's and howard's
our chances have equalized
before one of our shots was answered
with 50 shots from them
today the ratio is one to four
or one to five
are the u.s supplied long-range mobile
rocket launchers which have allowed
ukraine to hit deep behind russian lines
countries have pledged almost 90 billion
euros worth of equipment or military
financing the us is by far the biggest
donor followed by the united kingdom and
the european union poland is number four
its donations include howitzer artillery
vehicles like these to replace ukraine's
soviet era tanks and cannon
i think the advance is more successful
on our side because our equipment is
more modern we attack the occupiers more
precisely
germany is the fifth biggest military
donor it has now pledged almost 2
billion euros worth of aid including
anti-aircraft vehicles and training for
troops to operate them
the men who are here will defend their
country
they will defend it against the terrible
threat posed to ukraine by russia's
brutal war of aggression
and we will continue to support them
with our financial capabilities but also
with weapons
and private individuals have also sent
millions to help ukraine buy drones for
its fleet of eyes in the sky
foreign support has been crucial in
keeping ukraine's resistance efforts
afloat and helping it defend its
territory for longer than anyone
expected
here's dw's alexander for naaman in
prague with more on what eu defence
ministers will discuss today
there are two main issues on their
agenda arms deliveries for instance we
just saw that eu member states are
providing ukraine with all kinds of
military equipment but those deliveries
are depleting their stocks so the
question here is and the
defense ministers are going to discuss
that how they can push the industry to
produce more some of them are suggesting
that they need more european funding
some of them are in favor of joint
procurement of weapon systems or
ammunition and another topic that is
here on the agenda is a high level
training mission for the ukraine an army
eu foreign policy chief joseph burrell
told us that he is expecting the defense
ministers to give their political
backing for such a training mission we
know that some member states friends or
germany or denmark there are already
training ukrainian soldiers but the goal
here is for the european union to
coordinate such a mission and to finance
it
and eu foreign ministers are also
meeting to discuss visa restrictions for
russian travelers
yes visa restrictions for russian
citizens are looming large over the
meeting of the foreign ministers later
today here in prague with many member
states demanding a total ban on
russian visas of of on tourist
visas however
some member states among them friends
and germany oppose such a ban germany
and friends circulated a paper ahead of
the meeting he's saying that it's
important to respect the people to
people exchange that it's important that
russian artists opposition figures or
intellectuals students are still able to
come to the european union so as you can
see there is little appetite for the
moment for such a total ban but i think
with many eastern european and baltic
states demanding such a step this
discussion is here to stay
alexander for naaman for us in prague
thank you very much